wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
bald fahren wir gemeinsam in den urlaub
und du glaubst dass es eine gute idee
ist ja wieso der nicht im gegensatz zu
den meisten männern ist chuck
rücksichtsvoll charmant humorvoll
romantisch was heißt denn im gegensatz
zu den meisten männern ja viele männer
sind unsensibel und reagieren
verständnislos wenn sie ja es tut mir
leid aber klischees werden nicht bedient
ich es weiter aber heute auch sensibel
warum haben wir deinen job eigentlich
noch nicht gesehen hast du kein foto von
ihm oder sieht ja vielleicht gar nicht
so gut aus wie du mir sagst
jetzt wird bloß nicht frech sagt es sehr
attraktiv ist groß und schlank er hat
schöne augen und moment kann ich das
bitte noch mal sehen
dass orte der fahrradhändler von jahre
wiegelte ein fahrradhändler so ein
quatsch das ist ja ich sage nur so
aussieht und wie so wenig überhaupt mit
euch weil uns max klinger und weil wir
immer noch die besten köche sind wie du
kennst